When it comes to raw power, nothing
gives a devil fruit user the
edge like a zoan fruit. But which of
these fruits is the most beastly of all?
Today we’re counting down the top 5
strongest zoan devil fruits in One Piece,
but quick spoiler warning for some
very recently revealed fruits!
First off, what’s a zoan in the first place?
This category of fruits allows its users to
transform into various animals. From cobras, to
falcons, to allosauruses these fruits bestow the
greatest raw strength, endurance, and speed
of any fruit category. They even include
ancient and mythical subsets - ancient zoans being
based on extinct creatures and mythical zoans,
the rarest of all fruits, being
based on mythological figures.
And no surprise here, #5 is a mythical zoan:
The Inu Inu no Mi: Model Okuchi no Makami.
Yamato has only been in the series for a short
while, but is already a fan favorite character.
And they have already proven themselves to have
one of the most powerful fruits in the series -
the guardian deity of Wano, the Okuchi no Makami,
that can even go toe to toe with Kaidou himself.
So…how did we decide this anyway? Well,
this ranking isn’t arbitrary. In fact,
we’ve chosen our devil fruit rankings in a
highly scientific manner. In an exhaustive
and time-consuming process,
we’ve given all of the series’
139 devil fruits a score out of 100
based on six different criteria.
First: Strength. What kind of raw
power does the devil fruit have?
How effectively can this
fruit attack its opponents?
Second, Endurance: Does this fruit
offer any defensive capabilities
or resistances against the attacks of others?
Third, Special Abilities: Besides general
combat prowess, does this fruit have
any secondary abilities worth awarding
points? To illustrate an example,
Miss Merry Christmas’s mole fruit wouldn’t
have a ton of strength or endurance, but its
tunneling abilities would give it
several points in this category.
The fourth category is Everyday Use:
Let’s say that hypothetically you had
this power in real life - how useful
would it be in non-combat situations?
Would the power come in handy even if you
weren’t engaged in intense pirate battles?
Each of these four categories was given a score
out of 25 for a grand total of
100 available points. However,
there are two additional categories that
can deduct points from these scores.
Firstly, we have Weaknesses: A great example
for a weakness is Enel’s natural weakness
against rubber. If there are any glaring
weaknesses like this, points can be deducted.
Second in the negative categories are
Drawbacks. Are there any problems that
arise from having this fruit? An
example here would be Whitebeard’s
Quake-Quake fruit. Even though it has immense
raw power, it also has a high chance of causing
collateral damage to your own allies. Therefore,
it would lose a few points in this category.
**Back to Yamato’s fruit, the Okuchi
no Makami. With a total of 75 points,
let’s look at how it earned the #5 spot.**
For both strength and endurance, the Makami earned
20 points each. With strength and durability,
it’s important to factor in a user’s haki as
well. Yamato can go toe to toe with Kaidou,
but a lot of that is due to their haki ability
and not necessarily the fruit itself. For these
point totals, we based Yamato’s stats
off of the strength and endurance of
a wolf. While Yamato’s fruit is strong,
a wolf doesn’t have the same kind of raw
strength or defense that for instance a
dinosaur or elephant would have. However,
a wolf is still a fierce predator and
earns a lot of points in these areas.
What helped the Okuchi no Makami beat out a lot of
other fruits, though, are its special abilities.
Having additional ice powers, almost like a bonus
paramecia fruit on top of the benefits of a zoan,
helped Yamato earn 20 points in the Special
Abilities category. This category yields great
benefits to mythical zoans, who get all sorts
of powers in addition to their transformations.
For Everyday Use, Yamato earns 15
points - having the speed, agility,
and strength of a wolf could certainly come
in handy in all sorts of situations. And hey,
those ice powers are going to
come in handy on a hot summer day.
It’s not the most useful fruit outside of combat,
but you will have the frostiest
beverages in all of Wano.
With the Makami, there are no downsides
either, so Yamato doesn’t lose any points.
**On to number #4. Ryu Ryu no Mi:
Model Pteranodon. Total Points: 86**
King’s fruit and other ancient zoans are among the
toughest of the tough when it comes to
strength and endurance. In these categories,
King earned a 23 in each. You can’t get much
stronger than a dinosaur - so the Pteranodon
earns more points in these categories
than fruits like giraffes or leopards.
What sets the Pteranodon over the edge and
makes it one of the greatest zoan fruits of
all is its special ability: flight. Any flying
fruit automatically scores big points for both
special abilities and everyday use. In both of
these areas, King scores 20 points. Flying grants
huge advantages in combat, and it also helps a
fruit user circumvent a lot of the drowning risk
that comes with having a devil fruit because they
can simply fly above the ocean. Very convenient.
Not only that, but just like Pteranodons
did in the Cretaceous Period, the user of
this fruit can stretch their face backward in
order to launch devastating projectile attacks.
And as for everyday use, do I
really have to explain that? I mean,
who among us would not love
to have the power of flight?
As for disadvantages, King loses no points. Lucky
for him, there aren’t really any
downsides to being a Pteranodon.
**#3. Uo Uo no Mi: Model Seiryu
(Azure Dragon). Total points: 90**
Beating out his first mate for the #3 spot is
Kaidou himself. Of course the world’s strongest
creature had to be on this list. Kaidou
scored perfect marks in the strength and
endurance categories. He also had perfect marks
in the special abilities category - he has the
same flight as King as well as flame clouds that
can lift entire islands. He also utilizes blast
breaths and all sorts of other special, unique
techniques. It seems like the longer Wano goes on,
the more special powers Kaidou pulls out. He
gets 20 points for Everyday Use as well because,
again, flight would just be
fantastic to have in real life.
However, this is the first fruit where a
drawback comes into play. Many fruits don’t
have any drawbacks whatsoever, but there’s one
big one I can think of when it comes to Kaidou.
He’s massive. Just absolutely huge. Which is
great, until you want to fight someone *indoors*.
During the raid on Onigashima, he had no
choice but to take things outside with the
Akazaya 9. His unwieldy size makes him so
destructive that he’s at risk of destroying things
he doesn’t want to destroy, such as his own home.
This is great when you’re attacking an enemy base,
but not so great during an enemy raid.
For this drawback, Kaidou loses 5 points.
There’s also some speculation that Kaidou’s fruit
wasn’t so useful when he first got it. As we know,
his fruit is not a Dragon fruit, but a Fish
fruit. It’s possible that he only achieved his
current strength after a Magikarp-esque
ordeal. However, until we get the long
awaited Kaidou flashback, we can’t allow
this theory to affect Kaidou’s score.
**Up next might be a surprise to many of you who
may have expected this fruit to be number 1. With
94 points, we have #2: Monkey D. Luffy’s
fruit - the Hito Hito no Mi: Model Nika.**
This is a fruit we’ve known for a long time but
have only just learned is a mythical zoan. It’s
hard to rate given that we haven’t seen the
full extent of its abilities, but clearly its
endurance is off the charts. Luffy’s pliable,
rubber body can take beating after beating.
Its strength is also maxed out given
the ability to deliver just about
any attack one can imagine. Punching with
a fist the size of an island comes to mind.
Its special abilities are, of course, also
crazy and I’m sure we’ve only scratched the
surface of what Oda has planned for the fruit.
So far, we’ve seen Luffy throwing lightning,
and imbuing both the ground and his opponent with
rubber-like qualities as well. These, of course,
are on top of the wide range of abilities
that Luffy utilized in his base form and
the other gears. So for each of the first
three categories, this fruit earns 25 points.
Everyday use gets 20 points - a considerable
score, but not maxed out. He can fly in a
roundabout, bouncy sort of way. He can
reach hard to reach places. However,
it just doesn’t have the kind of practical
usage that we see from some other fruits.
It does, however, lose a small number of
points. Unlike a lot devil fruits that don’t
have a specific weakness, all the way since East
Blue it’s been stated that Luffy is vulnerable
to blades and cutting attacks. Recently, even
Kaidou commented that Luffy is vulnerable to
slicing attacks in Gear 5th. Obviously, Luffy has
survived plenty of cuts, but since this weakness
is explicitly stated so many times, the fruit
was docked 3 points in the weakness category.
**And that’s unfortunate for Luffy, because
coming in at #1 with 96 points - just two
more than the Nika fruit…is the
Tori Tori no Mi: Model Phoenix!**
Marco’s fruit gained 22 points for strength and
24 points for durability. While not the most
physically powerful zoan, his regenerative
properties assisted a bit with his durability.
Given that he was just fine holding his own
against both King and Queen, two powerful
ancient zoans with immense raw strength,
it made sense to rate these areas highly.
His special abilities received a perfect score
of 25 as well. Not only does he have the enviable
ability of flight, but he can use his flames to
heal others as well. This also gives him a perfect
score in the everyday use category because being
able to heal others would be a wonderful trait
to have in the real world. Any hospital would be
lucky to have Marco the Phoenix on their staff.
If it turns out that like the mythical phoenix,
Marco is even able to revive from death,
this score may become even higher one day.
But until then, it’s just speculation. With no
weaknesses or drawbacks to speak of, the Phoenix
is the greatest zoan devil fruit in One Piece.
It just so happens that these five powerful
zoans are only exclusively of the mythivcal type,
but just like Luffy’s real fruit
was only revealed late in the story,
that might be true for another character as
well, Blackbeard. If you want to find out why
he might make it onto this list very very soon,
you should really not miss out on this video here.